- [Voiceover] Hello everyone.
So I'm gonna start talking about curl.
Curl is one of those very
cool vector calculus concepts,
and you'll be pretty happy
that you've learned it
once you have, if for no other reason
because it's kind of
artistically pleasing.
And, there's two different versions,
there's a two-dimensional curl
and a three-dimensional curl.
And naturally enough, I'll start talking
about the two-dimensional version
and kind of build our
way up to the 3D one.
And in this particular video,
I just want to lay down the intuition
for what's visually going on.
And, curl has to do with the
fluid flow interpretation
of vector fields.
Now this is something
that I've talked about
in other videos,
especially the ones on
divergents if you watch that,
but just as a reminder,
you kind of imagine
that each point in space is a particle,
like an air molecule or a water molecule.
And since what a vector field does
is associate each point in
space with some kind of vector,
now remember we don't always
draw every single vector,
we just draw a small sub-sample,
but in principle, every
single point in space
has a vector attached to it.
You can think of each particle,
each one of these water
molecules or air molecules,
as moving over time in such a
way that the velocity vector
of its movement at any given point in time
is the vector that it's attached to.
So as it moves to a
different location in space
and that velocity vector changes,
it might be turning or
it might be accelerating,
and that velocity might change.
And you end up kind of a
trajectory for your point.
And since every single
point is moving in this way,
you can start thinking about a flow,
kind of a global view of the vector field.
And for this particular example,
this particular vector
field that I have pictured,
I'm gonna go ahead and put a blue dot
at various points in space,
and, each one of these you can think of
as representing a water
molecule or something,
and I'm just gonna let it play.
And at any given moment,
if you look at the movement
of one of these blue dots,
it's moving along the
vector that it's attached to
at that point, or if that
vector's not pictured,
you know the vector that
would be attached to it
at that point.
And as we get kind of a
feel for what's going on
in this entire flow,
I want you to notice a
couple of particular regions.
First, let's take a look at this region
over here on the right.
Kind of around here.
And just kind of concentrate
on what's going on there.
And I'll go ahead
and start playing the animation over here.
And what's most noticeable
about this region
is that there's counterclockwise rotation.
And this corresponds to an
idea that the vector field
has a curl here, and
I'll go very specifically
into what curl means, but just right now
you should have the idea that in a region
where there's counterclockwise rotation,
we want to say the curl is positive.
Whereas, if you look at a
region that also has rotation,
but clockwise, going the other way,
we think of that as being negative curl.
Here I'll start it over here.
And in contrast, if you look at a place
where there's no rotation,
where like at the center here,
you have some points coming
in from the top right
and from the bottom
left, and then going out
from the other corners.
But there's no net rotation.
If you were to just put like a
twig somewhere in this water,
it wouldn't really be rotating.
These are regions where you think of them
as having zero curl.
So with that as a general idea,
clockwise rotation regions
correspond to positive curl.
Counterclockwise rotation regions
correspond to negative curl,
and then no rotation
corresponds to zero curl.
In the next video I'm
gonna start going through
what this means in terms
of the underlying function
defining the vector field
and how we can start looking
at the partial differential
information of that function
to quantify this intuition
of fluid rotation.
And what's neat is that it's
not just about fluid rotation.
If you have vector fields in other context
and you just imagine that
they represent a fluid,
even though they don't,
this idea rotation and curling
actually has certain importance
in ways that you totally wouldn't expect.
The gradient turns out
to relate to the curl,
even though you wouldn't
necessarily think the grading
has something to do with fluid rotation.
In electromagnetism, this
idea of fluid rotation
has a certain importance,
even though fluids
aren't actually involved.
So, it's more general than
just the representation
that we have here, but
it's a very strong visual
to have in your mind as
you study vector fields.